Speaker 1: Someone sent me a video yesterday that
I found fascinating because it reminded me of
someone that I've interviewed on the show who has
since passed away that I'm going to tell you about
in a moment. This is a video I'm going to play for
you of a Q and on person who believes that Trump
and JFK Jr., JFK Jr., not JFK, JFK Jr. a lot of
people are confused by which JFK are. They believe
that this person believes Trump and JFK Jr. are
currently the president and the vice president
and one of the delightful things I love. Hyper
specific conspiracy theories As many of you know,
this guy also claims that mortgages are invalid,
that more that as soon as you sign a mortgage,
the mortgage is paid off. If some of our older
listeners might remember who this should remind
us of. So let's look at this clip first. Sure.
Speaker 6: Sure. You know, all mortgages in the
United States are fraud. Every one of
them. Everyone is fried. Did you know
your mortgage was paid off?
The association, think of that
your mortgage was paid off the moment you sign the
mortgage application and they accepted it. Whoa.
You know who paid it off? No, you did, huh?
See, you're not a debtor, you're a
creditor, you just don't know it.
You don't know what they want you to think you're
a debtor and that you're indebted to them. Hmm.
Your signature paid off that loan immediately
and you don't know what to do. Oh,
OK, I'm going to teach you guys what
Speaker 1: so this is. I don't know why I find
this fascinating. So who does this remind me of?
This is a great dip into the archives for some of
our younger viewers. There's this guy who passed
away in 2019. His name was David Wynn Miller,
and I interviewed him years ago and during the
interview. I'm not going to play it for you now,
but you can look it up. It's about 10 20 minutes
long. He said things that like, for example,
that he is the king of Hawaii as one example that
he syntax the Magna Carta. But David Wynn Miller
is big thing was that you can make yourself
a nontaxable entity to the United States with
something that he called quantum grammar and the
inclusion of extraneous punctuation marks in your
name. So like his name was David Wynn Miller, but
he would put like a colon before David and then a
dash between David and Wynn. And he believed that
by becoming quantum grammar, you were no longer
taxable and people tried doing this stuff and
they were they were sometimes held in contempt
by courts. So here's a little bit of what David
Wynn Miller used to do this Cunanan guy. It seems
just like the next version of David Wynn Miller.
Speaker 6: When we went to school, they taught
us that a sentence must be one thought,
right? So we have a we have a one venue
or one condition of thought, which is a
correct pass. Syntax, grammar, passé syntax.
Speaker 1: Grammar was a favorite word of his.
And if you're looking at this, you also see
that he has hyphens between like every word on
his whiteboard. That was another thing he did.
Speaker 6: However, in the world of
fraud, which means you're going to have
going to the store from the house now we have two
different time factors of from and two, which is
now a lie because now we have two conditions of
time and it's no longer a single thought sentence.
So this generates when you're into fraud.
Fiction lies, perjury, false guessing,
presumption assumption.
Speaker 1: Yeah, when my dad was a psychiatrist,
when I did the interview with David Wynn Miller
years ago, I showed it to him and I said,
What do you what do you think about this guy?
He's not diagnosing anyone in any formal way.
Everybody relax. My dad said, this guy strikes
me as what's called a para phrenic. It's not a
schizophrenic. A pair of phrenic is someone who
has a highly organized set of of delusions without
hallucinations. This guy is not hallucinating. He
just it's a very organized, sort of like gated set
of delusions. And outside of that, they seem
like normal people. So sometimes when you have
like a paranoid, delusional or schizophrenic, you
can't have a normal conversation with them about
anything. It's when you speak to them. They're
very clearly totally out of touch with reality.
You can't talk about the grocery store, you
can't talk about sports or whatever. David Wynn
Miller My dad's instinct, not a formal diagnosis
was this is this is a paraphrase NEA with this
grammar stuff. It's highly organized and limited.
And outside of that, you can seemingly have
a normal conversation with the guy. Here's one
more video from from one of these weird seminars.
Speaker 6: 90 second degree mason is because
in 1988, I broke the math interface in all 5000
languages, proving that language was a linear
equation in algebra. Right? This hasn't been
done in 8500 years of written language.
Speaker 1: He broke the math language
interface. Maybe he could fix my toaster.
Speaker 6: When I did so, I was able to
unlock the two thirds of all the words
missing from all languages in the world,
and I can write any sentence in any language,
front words and backwards with the same meaning.
Speaker 1: Yeah, even the memory languages,
he's able to write forwards and backwards. So
bizarre stuff and the Q and on guy, it's like the
same thing. Let me explain grammatically why you
are really the one who is owed the money on the
mortgage or whatever the case may be. Wacky stuff,
but the point is all of this stuff recycles.
I've told you guys that a lot of the modern
revolutionary left, sometimes they're called
tank, but it's not a it's sort of a pejorative.
The modern revolutionary left are really similar
to the 60s era sort of socialist communists that
were really common in South America. They were in
Argentina where I was born and in other countries.
It's a rehashing of the same ideas in the same
ideology and the same sort of tone and tenor.
And even the Q and on stuff isn't really new
when they get into these technicalities about
grammar and syntax. David, when Miller did
this stuff? Or 30 years? May he rest in peace